There are a number of ways to improve the
efficiency of aircraft: Shape, fuel, engine
efficiency, even the material the airplane
is made of.
One study from 2004 looked at shaping wings
more like humpback whale flippers -- complete
with weird bumps -- makes them more efficient,
creates more lift and less drag than sleeker
shapes.
But while the engineers plan the look of new
future planes, the more imminent impact is
on the environment.
Just in the last year there have been a number
of proposed "new" planes that are more efficient,
more sleek, or just plain MORE, but one thing
is clear -- current jet fuels are out.
The Chief Technology Officer at Boeing told
the BBC last year, "Probably 75% of the research
and development dollars we invest in the commercial
airplane side goes towards improving our environmental
footprint."
A single flight from New York to San Francisco
or Europe creates 2 to 3 tons of greenhouse-causing
gasses.
In a year, the average European generates
10 tons of carbon dioxide a year; the average
American?
19.
A Boeing 747 uses about 1 gallon of fuel per
second (4L) or about 5 gallons per mile and
there are around 7,000 flights over the US
at any given moment.
And that is SO MUCH FUEL to replace, but that
also makes for a huge market.
At the end of 2014, the world's first biofuel
powered plane took off in Canada.
The biofuel was made using rapeseed oil, though
the researchers pointed out it could have
just as easily come from flax, coconut husks,
cooking oil or algae.
Even though it releases CO2 when burned, biofuel
is considered carbon neutral, because the
plants it's made from absorbed CO2 as they
grow.
Though MIT studies show that it might not
be QUITE as "Green" as first thought; it all
depends on the crops used and the way they're
harvested.
More research def needed.
Other fuels are being explored too.
Manufacturer Airbus is exploring hydrogen
fuel cells not for the engines, but for the
internal power -- replacing the gas turbine
engines that currently provide on-board electrical
systems.
Hydrogen fuel cells could provide enough power
for the plane, but ALSO create fresh water
right there on board!
They're even looking into hydrogen-powered
front wheels, for emission-free taxiing while
on the ground.
Earlier this year Boeing and NASA launched
the ecoDemonstrator -- a 757 which doesn't
burn a new fuel, but DOES improve efficiency.
The plane's tail is 17 percent smaller, and
contains tiny forced-air jets to stabilize
the plane during take-off and landing; increasing
rudder efficiency up to 20 percent!
At the speeds airlines fly, a chip in the
paint or misplaced rivet will increase drag
costing fuel and polluting more; but so will
bug splatters!
So they've developed a few new insect-repellant
coatings to reduce the drag cost from insect
strikes.
Sure, efficiency isn't super sexy, but even
a small increase can mean thousands of gallons
of fuel saved, plus it's better for the environment.
The crazytown airplane award has to go to
Solar Impulse, though, for forgoing fuel altogether.
The Solar Impulse is flying around the world
powered only by light from the sun.
Though at the moment they're trapped in Japan
trying to fly from there to Hawaii and wrap
this shiz up.
It's not exactly market-ready, but it's a
proof of concept!
They're proving it!
YOU CAN DO IT SOLAR IMPULSE!!
In the end, airplanes are 20th century technology
that's being innovated into the 21st century.
It's slow going, but it's GOING.
Petroleum packs a lot of umph for it's weight,
which is key on an airplane.
Maybe, like with the automobile industry,
different engines are needed for different
jobs.
Hydrogen-powered jet engines to get off the
ground, and hyper-efficient pulse detonation
engines or wind generators for cruising -- like
an airplane hybrid.
That, combined with more efficient wings,
and fuel cells and solar for electricity…
and we'd be well on our way.
So even though the idea of an “eco-friendly”
plane sounds like a pipe dream, there are
many people trying to make it a reality.
Meanwhile on the road, Toyota is fueling the
future with the new Toyota Mirai.
Using the most abundant element in the universe,
Hydrogen, the new Mirai is looking to the
future with sustainability in mind.
What do you think?
Have an idea that could make planes better?
Tell us in the comments.